people thinking that space equals no
gravity so I just want to tease this out
of people's misunderstanding it is zero
g because there's no net gravitational
force acting on them but if you are in
orbit around Earth right aim towards
where the moon will be when they get
there if you're in space and your
engines are shut off you will be falling
to
happen to be in a LaGrange Point
all I'm saying is if you are coasting
then you are Falling Towards wherever is
pulling you they have transluter
injection which is enough speed to make
it to one of the LaGrange points between
Earth and the Moon that's called L1 the
Earth's pull towards Earth equals the
moon pull towards the Moon
oh foreign
[Music]